foreign
is with us in Boston Hi rashonda how are
you
I'm great thank you good how can we help
so I am in a little bit of I have a
current stressor right now concerning
um some past debt I I incurred when I
was in my early 20s I'm 27 now and I'm
learning very quickly after my 25th
birthday I am paying dearly in my late
coming for a mistakes I've made
financially in my early 20s my current
stressor would be my car debt my car
loan
um it's my second vehicle and
um I got it a year ago from February
from Valentine's Day and
I am wondering if I'm I don't have
really many options because I I rolled
over negative equity
and right now I'm looking at roughly 31
000 for the payoff on this car it's a
Lexus it's a 2016 Lexus and
um I am wondering I know you say not to
get what you call fleece but
I'm wondering if just to kind of cushion
and alleviate some of that stress right
now have you looked up what the car is
worth
I did a kbd yeah on what the mileage is
for it now and it's roughly 16 650. uh
uh on a private sailor trade-in
on a trade-in
okay so private shall be 20. and you're
31 000 did you say you leased this
no I initially I finance
your actual payoff is really Thirty one
thousand
correct you're sure of that
correct um last time I checked
my interest is like almost nine percent
now when you said this was your second
vehicle you're you're meaning that you
had a vehicle and you rolled the equity
the negative equity into this not that
you own two vehicles right
correct okay just double checking that
what's your income
my I just started a new job I'm a
student so uh
it's kind of choppy my I work I earn
like 15 an hour I literally just started
that job but I am I've always had a job
it's just on a normal month how much
money do you bring home
on a normal month I'll say right at 4
000.
um and I assume you have no money
correct okay is this the only debt you
have
or is there more no I have credit card
debt before the loan how much
uh I'll say that is about thirteen
fourteen thousand
okay
well there's no question mathematically
this is killing you and I feel I made
some very stupid well I feel like me too
I've done it too but I mean I feel the I
feel the math pinch in these numbers
you're this is a real problem it's a
real struggle for you and so what
happened is you had a car that you're
upside down in and then you bought
another car and you're further upside
down and yet and so we've double dipped
we've got a double hole you know that's
where ten thousand dollars comes from
because you're roughly ten thousand
dollars in the hole
um
you don't have money saved anywhere do
you no she doesn't no we already asked
you no no
yeah yeah yeah
I was my my question was I thought I
would have the option I researched it I
don't think that's an option my question
because I mind you I've exhausted as
much as I can in terms of just looking
at my bank and then other I thought well
if I try to lease it
um Coulda or if I don't leave it could I
try to sell it privately put that money
toward the debt and then get my credit
or not the debt my credit card get the
credit score up and then try to get a
consumer loan and put that to work I
said no because that's I think that's
technically illegal because I don't have
the title if I try to sell it well you
won't be able to get the title unless
you pay it off yeah who's got the loan
who holds the loan
uh my bank nfcu have you talked to them
about
do you have a local branch there
no the closest one is about 70 miles
away Newport Rhode Island okay I would
try to get someone on the phone there
and discuss with them the idea that you
sell the car they release the title and
you sign a note a personal loan of
credit a personal loan for the
difference the ten thousand dollar
difference
um because that's really where they are
today anyway they're not fully
collateralized on this loan they only
have a twenty thousand dollar cars
collateral against a thirty one thousand
dollar loan and by selling it they have
a better chance of getting their money
you follow me okay and so but it's it it
long distance on a phone call with a
bank like that I you know I give you
less than 50 chance you pull it off but
if you can talk them into it that is
your best case scenario your next best
case scenario is uh find a credit union
a local bank just a loan you ten
thousand dollars again very difficult
but uh you've got to cover the ten
thousand dollar hole to get out of this
either with the current bank accepting a
note for that amount
um or you coming up with a cash by
signing a note somewhere else but I
would rather you be ten thousand dollars
in debt somewhere else even on a credit
card if you could get a ten thousand
dollar credit card I would rather be
that than be thirty thousand dollars in
debt on this car now of course that
leaves you Carlos right she's got to get
something to do that and so then you've
got to work like a crazy person and
scratch together a thousand two thousand
dollars and pay cash for a little garage
sale car something that's pitiful you
need a pitiful car
that you pay cash for with no payments
pitiful and no payments and then that
breaks the back on this cycle but there
is no lease on it there's no leasing it
that's not going to work because all of
it's going to be rolled into that anyway
yeah the 31 000 is going to be rolled
into that and it's still it doesn't go
away your payment is your payment is
your payment and your lease payment
might actually be higher and so um
that's easier so yeah but the trick is
uh working your tail end off taking like
8 000 hours of work I mean you just work
until you're about to drop you know go
go work six jobs whatever you've got to
do scratch together some money and or
borrow that some portion of that ten
thousand dollar hole that you're in put
that and then if someone comes along and
gives you twenty thousand dollars for
the car you put the ten thousand dollars
from the loan or the work with it that
gets the car paid off and you can give
the title to them but you're going to
have this other loan over to the side
you see what I'm saying
okay but you can't sell the car to
someone unless you can give the bank
Thirty one thousand dollars or they will
agree to let you sign a note for the
difference
and release the title The title's got to
be released on the transaction
it's not illegal it's just the buyer
won't do it
okay because nobody buys a car you don't
get the title
okay it's pretty scary in Massachusetts
they don't play games about life yeah
well they shouldn't they shouldn't I
mean you shouldn't sell a car you can't
get the title I mean so you've got it
but you can get it all set up to where
it's perfectly legal what I'm describing
is perfectly illegal in any state
because if you give them 31 000 or they
agree to let you sign a note for the
difference doesn't matter they're gonna
that you know they've you've now got a
way to release the title to the buyer
and that's what you have to do that yeah
because once she comes up with the
difference they don't know the
difference I mean she's just giving them
the money for the car so of course
they're going to give her the title so
if you find somebody to loan you 10 and
you put on the market for 20
you know and you can get Joe to buy it
for 20. Joe gives you 20. you give him a
bill of sale and you know you put the
other 10 with it and now you've got a
clear title to Canada Joe and that's the
process that you'll use but yeah that's
what you're gonna have to scratch and
Claw to get out of this because it's a
deep hole I'm so sorry yeah that's been
in that kind of mess it's no fun
that's a tough hole to get out of but
you can get out of it and you will get
out of it absolutely